ils sont près de 700 artistes à y avoir
séjourné le petit moulin des vaux de
cernay et retrace dans une exposition
son passé artistique avec des toiles de
peintres tels que celle de léon germain
pelouse et des objets prêtés par des
passionnés l'exposition du moulin invite
à la balade dans les paysages des veaux
de cerner les mêmes qui ont inspiré les
peintres au 19e siècle
c'est la première fois qu'elle n'est pas
un paysagiste de de cernay
se retrouvent réunis dans un seul lieu
donc leurs tableaux sont dispersés dans
plusieurs musées de france même à
l'étranger
pour près de 700 enfants sans passer par
le vote fermaient deuxième moitié du
siècle
aimer l'histoire antérieure du moulin
mais pas oublier niché au coeur du site
classé des vaux de cernay
il était autrefois la propriété des
moines de l'abbaye toute proche avant
d'être détenue par un meunier les objets
en fait quand on l'ignoré normalement
l'existence au sein du parc on les a
découverts au cours de ce projet quand
on fait le parc avait acquis il ya
longtemps des objets
qui est qui était en fait retrouvé dans
une ferme du parc les objets de
de la pisciculture les objets de
lavandières encore des bottes sabots
pour révéler dans les espaces humides
présenté sur deux étages l'exposition
retrace les huit cents ans d'histoire du
moulin pour pourquoi pas redevenir ce
lieu de balade si prisée au 19e siècle